a new report claims president Trump's
businesses were bleeding red ink while
he bragged about art of the art of the
deal
New York Times looked at IRS tax current
transcripts and information from the
president's tax forms and found more
than 1 billion dollars in losses from
1985 to 1994 mr. Trump lost so much
money he did not pay income taxes in
eight of those ten years one of his
lawyers told The Times that the
statements quote about the president's
tax returns and businesses from 30 years
ago are highly inaccurate wheeshes
Jenning is at the White House we did
good morning good morning John the New
York Times reports President Trump
suffered business losses of 46.1 million
dollars in 1985 alone but despite losing
so much money he did not see a decline
in his standard of living because most
of the wealth belonged to banks and
investors plus he leaned on his father I
got a small loan started a business and
it's now worth billions and billions and
billions of dollars
president Trump brands himself as the
deal maker in chief promising supporters
he navigates the presidency like he does
his businesses cuz I'm a deal maker I
believe that I can put both sides
together but a New York Times
investigation reveals many of those were
duds losing 1.17 billion dollars over a
decade I did a lot of great deals and I
did him early and young the
investigation says in multiple years mr.
Trump appears to have lost more money
than nearly any other individual
American taxpayer and during this time
his best-selling book the art of the
deal was released in it he shares advice
about making money I've made a fortune
by using debt and if things don't work
out I renegotiate the debt I mean that's
a smart thing not a stupid thing and I
made a freely renegotiate the debt
because you go back and you say hey
guess what the economy just crashed I'm
gonna give you back half
unlike other presidents mr. Trump has
never made any of his tax returns public
he has brushed off the question why not
men
many times I had no problem with it but
while I'm under on it I would not give
my taxes what about a summary though you
don't learn very much from text hey John
you don't learn very much from tax
returns let me tell you right now
just this week Treasury Secretary
Stephen minuchin defied a request from
House Democrats to release president
Trump's tax returns claiming the request
lacks a legitimate legislative purpose
Democrats who want to beat mr. Trump in
2020 are already making his finances an
issue hey president Trump my wife and I
just released 10 years please do the
same let the American president Trump
has apparently seen this investigation
just minutes ago he tweeted his response
saying real estate developers in the 80s
and 90s were entitled to massive
write-offs and depreciation he goes on
to say it was almost sports to
renegotiate with banks I think he was
talking about this with you Nora
now our CBS News business analyst Joe
Schlesinger says it is normal for
small-time investors to claim a loss but
nothing for something like this for
someone who's claiming such large ones
and investing billions of dollars over
years those numbers are stunning we Jay
thank you